if you bought something crappy here's a
return policy that'll make you happy i
guess some retailers may let you keep
your unwanted purchases
instead of returning them
fun fact sex toys have been doing this
for years
that isn't fun
but it turns out it's more of a hassle
for them to take care of returns thanks
to the supply chain crisis and soaring
gas prices stores like target walmart
gap say they already have too much
inventory which costs a lot to store in
other words some of our products are so
bad just keep them
it's amazing just letting you keep your
unwanted items and give you your money
back too this is more exciting than
finding an onion ring in your french
fries
so i guess now is probably the perfect
time to buy gold
and be dissatisfied
take that devine
[Laughter]
there must be some limit though to what
you're allowed to keep right
if people were forced to keep things
they no longer wanted
jaime would still be married
[Laughter]
i'm sorry i did not write that one of
the comedians wrote that
so you can blame them lara do you return
things oh it's a pain in the neck well
first of all i am the worst because i
don't like to go in a store and try
things on so i over order
knowing i can just ship it back and
return it very easy they usually include
the you know the label you just pop
right on there but this whole thing is
really kind of crazy yeah what could
possibly go wrong we're going to just
let you get your money back and you get
to keep your products i mean
and then you can sell your products on
the street of course you can't it's just
what i do you do it all the time exactly
yeah
no i'm the worst returner and my husband
hates it because we have boxes stacked
up everywhere always ready to go in the
mail sorry honey yeah you know it's it's
amazing brian that like this is like
we're in a we're in like a reverse world
it's like we
if we're in trouble we print more money
right create massive inflation and now
companies are like saying you know what
just keep the crap and take the money
we're going to go bankrupt all right so
here here's how confused i want about
this so tell me if i'm wrong here i
buy a jacket
and i get it home it doesn't fit or i
don't like the jacket i want to return
the jacket they say i'm going to give
you back your money keep it and you keep
your jacket
so
i could have lied yeah i could love the
jacket i could call up and i could say i
don't like my jacket right and they
could say here's your money yes and i
keep the jacket right that's actually if
i did it
i could live with myself and do this
yeah right so
this is walmart this is target this is
the gap this is these are huge companies
why do one jacket why not go into the
place buy like 20 jacks
none of them fit and then you just go on
the street with the rack and you just
sell them for 30 you get your money back
and you sell them right and you're
helping them because they don't have to
store them they are applauding my crimes
i feel like i'm an accessory you are you
could turn this into a business or you
could actually steal them and then you
get out of jail in a couple hours and
you sell them the same way exactly same
thing smashing grab or buy and get
returns same thing
they are applauding theft
this makes sense to you
i i want to say no but on the other hand
it's kind of the same thing that i do in
what way oh like i will buy stuff not
like it and i like i need to return it
because i want to get my money back
but i just don't want to deal with it
yeah so then i just waste my money
that's what they're doing the same thing
they don't want to deal with it they're
like whatever because you know time
flies and something's just sitting in
the back of your closet yeah you'll get
it the next day you never do so it's
stupid but no less stupid than i am
[Laughter]
uh yeah do you have a lot of crap in
your divorced hobble
it's your bot that's just sitting there
got memories yeah tell you what i got
half as much as i used to
nicely done this is uh nicely done this
is crazy right uh
like as brian's saying i'm like every
person's going to take advantage of it
right i've read this 10 times
by the way by the way everybody while i
start talking here i feel like we're
going to start a criminal enterprise
absolutely yeah and they they're
involved yeah it's pretty but there are
some interesting um i know you're a
peloton dude i think greg great too yeah
so i'd write a peloton they have a
really good return policy do you know
they if you buy it they come and like
pick it up yes you have 90 days you can
ride it but i did this as they're
leaving with it they're like you're a
quitter
so
you're gonna right so they heckle i'm
gonna keep it but you know some stuff in
the article some of it kind of made
sense they said things that you can't
resell that it's like you might as well
keep them like like whatever clothes or
like you don't want to buy i mean i had
that happen once i bought a pair of yoga
pants and clearly someone else's junk
was etched in there
and um
i'll taste them every time i put them on
i felt i felt bad about myself
that's a sad sad story i can't even
follow it well you know what it's that's
what happens when you divorce yeah i
guess
buying used yoga pants off craigslist
most people do that but they don't do
them to wear them if you know what i
mean i do
i don't know what i mean
who's talking right now is it me oh i
gotta go coming up can a vaccine keep
you hearty for your next sexy party hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else